und gegenüber zum themenbereich arbeit
und soziales und nehme an es gibt eine
kleine
wechselbewegung im haus das der mann war
im bereich arbeit und soziales wird
nicht der minister sprechen hubertus
heil der in den agenturen angekündigt
hat dass bald die weichen gestellt sein
für die konkrete ausgestaltung der
rentenerhöhung im juli es wird nach all
dem was wir wissen hatte dort gesagt in
diesem jahr eine kräftige rentenerhöhung
geben das wird für irgendwie im
bundestag kerstin krise übernehmen die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin in
seinem ministerium ich kann nicht sagen
ob der minister einen anderen termin hat
oder ob der minister eventuell sogar
erkrankt ist das kann ich von dieser
warte ihn nicht sehen jedenfalls ist es
ja so dass er gestern hier die einzelnen
ministerien und die einzelnen minister
hier ihre politik vorstellen und da
fehlt dann natürlich der arbeitsminister
hubertus heil hat ja sein amt behalten
können und kerstin griese wird er
sicherlich gut ihnen hier vertreten die
spd wird sicherlich und die
krise die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin wird sicherlich auch
noch mal ausführen den kern dessen was
die spd durchsetzen wollte nämlich den
anstieg des mindestlohnes auf zwölf euro
pro stunde und die wird uns sicherlich
hier mitteilen dass diese initiative
dazu schon sehr bald ergriffen wird
damit dann an die zehn millionen
menschen so hat zumindest der
bundeskanzler gesagt eine ordentliche
ordentliche erhöhung bekommen werden
aber er hat sich aufgrund eines kontakt
zu einer positiv getestete personen
häusliche quarantäne begeben und deshalb
will ich ihnen heute unsere ziele in der
arbeits und sozialpolitik vorstellen
meine damen und herren die neue
bundesregierung will unser land gut und
gemeinsam durch dieses spannende
jahrzehnte steuert wir haben dazu ein
anspruchsvolles ziel für unsere politik
formuliert wir wollen mehr
schritt wagen und uns ist dabei
besonders wichtig dass wir mehr sozialen
fortschritt wagen in deutschland
sozialer fortschritt bedeutet das leben
für die menschen besser zu machen besser
zu machen durch respekt vor ihrer
leistung durch höheres einkommen durch
bessere vereinbarkeit von familie und
beruf sozialer fortschritt bedeutet auch
dass wir dabei alle mitnehmen nicht nur
die staaten gerade dann wenn sich so
viel ändert müssen sich alle auf die
soziale sicherheit in deutschland
verlassen können auf stabile renten auf
ein sozialstaat mit weniger bürokratie
der chancen und schutz bietet und diese
verlässlichkeit ist die große stärke
unseres landes wir haben eine der
wirksamsten stärksten und stabilsten
sozial starken der welt das hat auch die
korona krise gezeigt wir haben stabile
renten unsere soziale sicherung hat
funktioniert und das ist ein gutes
zeichen
und das ist auch wichtig in einer welt
des wandels den fortschritt den wir alle
wollen fortschritt braucht vertrauen
damit die menschen mit kommt meine damen
und herren sozialer fortschritt heißt
auch dass wir ein inklusives land sein
wollen dass wir deutschland barrierefrei
machen wollen und dass wir gerade für
menschen mit behinderungen mehr chancen
auf teilhabe am arbeitsmarkt schaffen
worden
sozialer fortschritt bedeutet auch dass
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer von
diesem bundle etwas haben denn wir
erleben in diesem jahrzehnt eine
zeitenwende auf dem arbeitsmarkt wir
haben die arbeitslosigkeit in den
letzten jahren mehr als halbiert man
muss sich das mal vorstellen heute sind
es fünf prozent
2005 hatten wir noch 13 prozent
arbeitslosigkeit wir haben die höchste
zahl der sozialversicherungspflichtigen
beschäftigung die es je in deutschland
gab ein rekordhoch von 34 millionen
menschen in
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung jugendarbeitslosigkeit ist
auf den niedrigsten stand seit der
deutschen einheit und das ist eine gute
ausgangslage
das problem ist ein anderes der in
vielen branchen und regionen fehlen
heute keine arbeitsplätze sondern
arbeitskräfte vor allem fachkräfte
obmann it-spezialisten ist bauarbeiter
oder pflegekraft in mehr und mehr
berufen kann man sich heutzutage den job
schon fast aussuchen und gleichzeitig
erfordern neue technologien und der
wandel in die zukunft auch neue
qualifikationen am band und im büro in
der autoindustrie genauso wie zb bei der
versicherung und unser ziel ist es dass
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
von heute die arbeit von morgen gut
machen können
und deshalb meine damen und herren
brauchen wir eine doppelstrategie auf
dem arbeitsmarkt erstens müssen wir die
folgen der pandemie auch in zukunft
weiter im griff behalten gerade jetzt
mit der omicron variante und dafür haben
wir vorsorge getroffen das
kurzarbeitergeld ist unsere brücke über
das tiefe tal denn das kurzarbeitergeld
sicher jobs und sichert damit
familieneinkommen
und 22 der tempo beim thema
fachkräftesicherung und das ist dringend
nötig dafür setzten wir vier prioritäten
erstens wir machen den weg frei für mehr
frauen auf dem arbeitsmarkt mit mehr
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf wir
wollen zum beispiel mit alltags
helferinnen und alltagshelfer die
menschen entlasten und das wird familien
helfen es für jobs aus der schwarzarbeit
holen ist entstehen gute und
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitsplätze
zweitens wir verbessern die
qualifizierte zuwanderung durch
abschaffung von arbeits verboten durch
die möglichkeit des spurwechsels und
durch den ausbau von sprach angeboten
das wird mehr fachkräfte zuwanderung
bringen
wir bringen langzeitarbeitslose zurück
auf den arbeitsmarkt und der soziale
arbeitsmarkt den wir begonnen haben das
ist ein erfolg ich weiß dass gerade aus
nordrhein westfalen diese soziale
arbeitsmarkt wird verstetigt damit haben
mehr menschen eine chance wir sorgen für
ausbildung statt aushilfsjob mit der
einführung des bürgergeldes und mit
neuen regeln die menschen künftig besser
befähigen in arbeit zu kommen
und viertens wir wollen weiterbildungs
weltmeister werden ein großer anspruch
aber das werden wir tun denn das
brauchen wir in finnland wir werden
angelehnt an das transformationsprozess
weiter geld mit einem qualifizierungs
geld die betriebliche weiterbildung
vorantreiben das ist gerade da wichtig
für ein erheblicher wandel ansteht ich
denke zum beispiel an die zulieferer
industrie in der automobilindustrie da
wird weiterbildung ganz wichtig sein mit
diesem vorhaben eröffnete chancen
chancen für millionen von menschen
chancen für neue fähigkeiten für
beruflichen aufstieg für besseres
einkommen so sieht sozialer fortschritt
aus
und sozialer fortschritt bedeutet nicht
zuletzt mehr leistungsgerechtigkeit und
mehr respekt auf dem arbeitsmarkt und
das betrifft besonders die frauen in
deutschland denn sie sind es die immer
noch am meisten konfrontiert sind bitter
mehrfachbelastung von familie und beruf
sie haben immer noch die niedrigeren
löhne immer noch häufiger prekäre
beschäftigung und niedrige renten und
gerade die frauen die unser land am
laufen halten ganz besonders in der
krise haben mehr verdient und deshalb
sage ich wir müssen mehr für die tun die
so viel für uns alle tun
deswegen haben wir die grundrente
eingeführt deswegen haben mit den pflege
mindestlohn erhöht und deswegen erhöhen
wir jetzt in allgemeinen mindestlohn auf
12 euro das ist ein plus von 22 prozent
der neue mindestlohn meine damen und
herren der neue mindestlohn ist eine der
größten lohnerhöhung in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik deutschland und davon
profitieren millionen menschen er wird
noch dieses jahr kommen und viele der
menschen die davon profitieren die
mehrheit werden frauen seien und deshalb
ist das ein guter und richtiger schritt
für mehr respekt auf dem arbeitsmarkt
das haben wir vor der wahl versprochen
das halten wir und das ist sozialer
fortschritt sozialer fortschritt den
arbeitsmarkt gut für die zukunft
aufstellen stabile renten soziale
sicherheit für alle menschen ein neues
bürgergeld mehr inklusion und
barrierefreiheit das ist der soziale
fortschritt für unser land ich freue
mich auf die zusammenarbeit das
bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales und der bundesminister selbst
freut sich auf die zusammenarbeit damit
wir gemeinsam mehr sozialen fortschritt
schaffen vielen dank
so wird also kassen diese die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin im
ministerium für arbeit und soziales und
sie hat es noch einmal angedeutet dieses
jahr soll also der mindestlohn auf 12
euro angehoben werden sie hat das gelobt
als eine der grössten lohnerhöhungen in
der industrie publik deutschland hermann
gröhe von der cdu/csu ist der nächste
redner er ist einer der stellvertretende
fraktionschef berlin zuständig für diese
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen und
seien leistungsfähiger sozialstaat
bewährt sich gerade in krisen darauf
sind wir stolz auf den beitrag den wir
in den letzten jahren im bereich der
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik geleistet
haben und auch die gute lage auf dem
arbeitsmarkt die arbeitslosigkeit sinkt
auch
2021 gehört zu unserer gemeinsamen
bilanz und ich freue mich dass die
geschätzte
staatssekretärin als bezugspunkt für die
erfolgsgeschichte auf dem arbeitsmarkt
das jahr 2005 gewählt hat das ist
richtig das war der beginn der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
auch als opposition werden wir unseren
beitrag zu einer zeitgemäßen
weiterentwicklung des sozialstaats und
zu seiner festigung leisten zugleich hat
sich in der krise gezeigt kraftvolle
solidarität braucht wirtschaftliche
stärke zwar hat unsere solide
finanzpolitik spielräume für umfassende
hilfen für wirtschaft und arbeitsplätze
ermöglicht und eine trotz der absenkung
des
arbeitslosenversicherungsbeitrag prall
gefüllte milliardenschwere reserve der
bundesagentur für arbeit ermöglichte
schnelle und umfassende verbesserungen
beim kurzarbeitergeld
dadurch konnten hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze gesichert werden dies
unterstreicht unsere überzeugung
wirtschaftliche vernunft und soziale
verantwortung
gehören untrennbar zusammen
das leitete uns beim regierungshandeln
und wird auch nun unser maßstab für die
bewertung ihres handelns sein damit
einher geht ein verständnis von
sozialstaatlichen handeln das auf so
viel befähigung zu eigenverantwortung
und ich habe so viel eröffnung von wegen
in den arbeitsmarkt wie möglich ziel
ausgehend von dieser leitlinie findet
manches in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
unsere ausdrückliche zustimmung
anderes hinterfragen wir kritisch oder
lehnen ist ganz ab unterstützung findet
die geplante entfristung des
teilhabechancen gesetzes die
förderinstrumente lohnkostenzuschuss und
intensive begleitung haben sich bewährt
auch der beabsichtigte ausbau der
förderung schwer zu erreichende junger
menschen ist sinnvoll erlauben sie mir
in diesem zusammenhang eine persönliche
anmerkung die schaffung dieser förderung
in paragraph 16 hsg b2 war unser vor
einem jahr verstorbenen kollegen karl
schiewerling ein besonderes anliegen ihm
wie viele von uns trägt der wunsch um
dass auch diese jungen leute erfahren du
wirst gebraucht ich freue mich über die
geplante ausweitung und denke dankbar an
einem großartigen kollegen
meine damen und herren auch die stärkung
der aus und weiterbildung findet unsere
grundsätzliche zustimmung es lohnt sich
arbeitslosigkeit am besten zu verhindern
indem rechtzeitig arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer auf veränderungen in der
arbeitswelt vorbereitet werden wichtig
ist dass geförderte weiterbildung immer
tatsächlich die chancen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt verbessern und eine
entsprechende förderung muss eigene
anstrengungen der wirtschaft und der
sozialpartner anreizen und darf nicht
dazu führen dass solche aktivitäten
zurückgefahren werden
meine damen und herren auch in der
sozialpolitik gilt nicht alles was
wünschenswert ist ist auch finanzierbar
leistungsversprechen ohne beantwortung
der frage nach ihrer finanzierbarkeit
sind nicht seriös schwächen das
notwendige vertrauen den sozialstaat ihr
koalitionsvertrag ist voller solcher
leistungsversprechen ohne preisschild so
reicht es in der rentenpolitik eben
nicht aus die beitragsentwicklung allein
in dieser wahlperiode im blick zu haben
so bleibt verlässlichkeit die
generationenvertrag auf der strecke
zudem fällt auf es fehlt bei ihnen an
einem klaren bekenntnis zur stabilität
bei den sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
steigende beiträge aber gefährden
arbeitsplätze und belaste gerade die
bezieher kleinerer einkommen und damit
möchte ich auch eine beratung zum thema
mindestlohn machen auch wir und was sie
seit klar hier festgestellt haben nichts
gegen einen spürbaren anstieg des
mindestlohns ja es gibt gute gründe
dafür aber wir sind gegen einen
politischen mindestlohn bei der
vorstellung der mindestlohn kommission
im februar 2015 unterstrich die damalige
arbeitsministerin andrea nahles dass man
einen solchen politischen mindestlohn
gerade nicht wolle weil dies so sagte
sie wörtlich willkür und populismus tür
und tor öffnet zitat andrea nahles und
gerade wenn man so stolz darauf ist ein
wahlplakat ins bundesgesetzblatt zu
bringen sollte man sich fragen ob man
nicht dieser gefahr erlegen ist sie
schwächen durch aushebelung von mehr als
100 tarifverträgen die
tarifpartnerschaft zu deren stärkung sie
sich zu recht an anderer stelle im
koalitionsvertrag bekennen das ist der
falsche weg zu einem nachvollziehbaren
ziel
die weiterentwicklung der grundsicherung
zu einem sogenannten bürgergeld ist
eines der größeren vorhaben dieser
regierung das zunächst experten den
vorschlag konkretisieren sollen ist
angesichts der komplexität sehr
verständlich aber bei einer debatte in
der letzten sitzungswoche zum im letzten
jahr über anträge der linken konnte man
nicht den eindruck gewinnen dass die
koalitionsfraktionen schon eine
gemeinsames verständnis von dieser
reform haben die einen sprachen über
eine bessere verzahnung von leistungen
und eine stärkere vermittlung in den
arbeitsmarkt die anderen von erhöhten
leistungen und abgesenkten mitwirkungs
erfordernissen unsere haltung ist klar
eine bessere verzahnung unterschied die
hilfesysteme und die stärkung der
vermittlung in den arbeitsmarkt findet
unsere zustimmung
einen schrittweisen weg in ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen lehnen
wir entschieden ab
und sie soll sind übrigens auch nicht so
tun als sei das weitgehend von spd und
grünen geschaffene system der
grundsicherung eine schikane die
leistungsbezieher entwürdigt das haben
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
den jobcentern wahrlich nicht verdient
meine damen 1 bei der rente wird es von
ihren konkreten vorschlägen abhängen ob
wir die alterssicherung die vertrauen
über lange zeiträume braucht weitgehend
im konsens gestalten wir sind dazu
bereit
dabei muss es vor allem um die
langfristige verlässlichkeit gehen die
aktivierung des nachholfaktor die
verbesserungen erwerbsminderungsrente
den bestand sehr kompliziert wegen der
unterschiedlichen erwerbsbiografien nach
rechtslage und die altersvorsorge
pflicht für selbstständige findet unsere
zustimmung
richtig ist es elemente der
kapitaldeckung ergänzend vorzusehen die
der notwendigen neustart in der privaten
altersvorsorge ist bisher an der spd
gescheitert die ihr wollen und auch in
der rentenversicherung selbst kann eine
solches element durchaus sinnvoll sein
wir haben 2015 mit dem pflegevorsorge
vor genau ein solches element in der
pflegeversicherung eingeführt ich sage
aber zehn milliarden für einen
kapitalstock werden bei weitem nicht
ausreichen um den beitragsanstieg auch
nur nennenswert abzubilden hier darf
nicht zu kurz gesprungen werden
insgesamt gilt wir werden ihre arbeit
kritisch und konstruktiv begleiten und
eigene vorschläge mit dem ziel machen
unseren sozialstaat weiterhin
zukunftsfest zu gestalten
herzlichen dank
dass er warf der bundesregierung fiel
leistungsversprechen ohne preisschild
voll vor es fehle an einem klaren
bekenntnis zu sozialer
sozial vorschlags betrieben ein
und er hat auf jeden fall gefordert dass
ein politischer mindestlohn
falsch sei so die vorsitzende gerade
gesagt dass die abstimmung wir noch zehn
minuten läuft da geht es ja um die wahl
der vertreter der bundesrepublik
deutschland in der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europäischen rates und
der nächste redner dank des die ist
mittlerweile sprecher für arbeit und
soziales der bündnisgrünen er war von
2001 bis 2009 10 vorsitzender der
gewerkschaft verdi
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
in weniger als 30 jahren eine
klimagerechte gesellschaft zu werden
bedeutet eine große eine wirklich große
veränderung veränderung löst aber auch
verunsicherung aus
arbeitnehmerinnen fragen sich was wird
aus meinem arbeitsplatz was wird wenn
erworbene qualifikationen nicht mehr
gebraucht werden habe ich noch chancen
am arbeitsmarkt und was für chancen
werden meine kinder haben wir grünen
nehmen das sehr ernst
der ökologische umbau
wirklich gelingen wenn das sozial auf
der strecke bleibt sozialer ausgleich
ist unverzichtbar und das bedeutet in
der alterssicherung dass es nicht zu
einem weiteren absinken des
rentenniveaus kommen und dazu dass die
rente immer mehr menschen nicht
ausreicht und man ständig über die
runden zu kommen
wir dürfen nicht länger wegschauen
dietrich bin und singt und
betriebsratswahlen behindert werden
tarifverträge schützen und ermöglichen
bessere arbeitsbedingungen
deshalb wollen wir das tarifsystem
stärken und die öffentliche
auftragsvergabe des bundes an die
einhaltung der präsentation rief
verträge finden
sowie weitere schritte zur stärkung der
tarifbindung erarbeiten die bildung von
betriebsratswahlen machen wir zum
offizialdelikt von mit der anhebung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns auf 12 euro
erhöhen wir die kaufkraft von rund acht
millionen beschäftigten um satte 98
milliarden euro das wirkt wie ein
kleines konjunkturprogramm und muss
umgehend in angriff genommen werden
keine frage
die digitale und ökologische
transformation der wirtschaft wird zu
massiven veränderungen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt führen umso wichtiger ist
eine arbeitsmarktpolitik die den
beschäftigten sicherheit und
perspektiven vermittelt deshalb machen
wir mit dem qualifizierungs geld die
kurzarbeit zu einem brücken instrument
für die transformation
damit kann die bundesagentur für arbeit
auf der grundlage von sozialpartner
vereinbarung unternehmen im
strukturwandel ermöglichen ihre
beschäftigten durch qualifizierung in
betrieb zu halten und fachkräfte zu
sichern
eine gute berufsausbildung ist das
fundament für einen guten einstieg ins
berufsleben mit einer
ausbildungsgarantie sorgen wir dafür
dass allen jugendlichen einen zugang zu
einer voll qualifizierende
berufsausbildung ermöglicht wird
ausbildungsbegleitende hilfen bauen wir
aus und gewährleisten auch geflüchteten
den zugang für menschen in
arbeitslosigkeit und grundsicherung
werden die berufsausbildung fördern und
zwar unabhängig von ihrer dauer die
vermittlung in arbeit wird nicht länger
vor rang berufliche aus und
weiterbildung haben und beruflicher
qualifizierung erhalten sgb 2 und 3
beziehen ein zusätzliches
weiterbildungsgeld als wirksamen anreiz
zur weiterbildung
wir wissen
fort- und weiterbildung werden den
umbrüchen in wirtschaft und
arbeitsgesellschaft zunehmend bedeutung
bekommen so unterstütze
berufsbegleitenden lernen wollen wir das
aufstiegs bafög aus und dann mit einer
geförderten bildungszeit beschäftigten
finanzielle unterstützung für
arbeitsmarkt bezogene weiterbildung
bieten
abgeordnete 12 euro mindestlohn
stabilisierung des rentenniveaus
stärkung der bericht bindung die
einführung eines qualifizierungs
kurzarbeitergeldes das waren ebenso wie
eine ausbildungsgarantie das
weiterbildungsgeld zusätzliche
weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten und
weiterbildungs agenturen forderungen mit
denen wir als grüne für den bundestag
kandidiert haben für eine andere eine
fortschrittliche klimagerechte und
zugleich sozialere politik in unserem
land und ich freue mich
ich freue mich heute sagen zu können wir
haben
zusammen mit unseren partnern geliefert
gemeinsam kommen wir voran gut so
nur noch nur noch ein wort in sachen
bürgergeld mit ihm wollen wir das hartz
iv system überwinden um
gesellschaftliche teilhabe ermöglichen
dazu wird in den ersten zwei jahren des
bürgergeld bezuges die leistung ohne
anrechnung des vermögens erbracht und
die angemessenheit der wohnung anerkannt
angebote und maßnahmen so die
mitwirkungspflichten sollen im rahmen
einer teilhabe vereinbar auch gemeinsam
vereinbart werden und anschließend eine
sechs monate vertrauens zeit gelten ohne
sanktionen des weiteren
wird im rahmen eines einjährigen
moratoriums auf die bisherigen
sanktionen verzichtet etwas anderes ist
und koalitionsvertrag nicht gedeckt was
immer auch sonst in die presse
hineinzutragen versucht wurde
abschließend
abschließend ökologische transformation
wird sozial hat sich herum zu verbinden
ist uns grün ein zentrales anliegen wir
sehen darin eine elementare bedingung
gelingenden klimagerechten wandels wie
für den erhalt unserer zukunft als
starker wirtschaft industrie und
beschäftigungsstandort
soweit dann besteht für die
bündnisgrünen ist sprecher für arbeit
und soziales und die anrede abgeordnete
pauschal so in den raum gestellt habe
ich hier auch noch nicht erlebt der
nächste gegner jetzt reni springer von
der hfg sprecher für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren frau staatssekretärin
reden wir über aktuelle probleme
die inflation hat einen stand von 53
prozent erreicht das ist der höchste
wert seit knapp drei jahrzehnten
die energiepreise gehen durch die decke
das heizen wird für immer mehr menschen
zum luxus diese war am montag so teuer
wie nie zuvor in der
nachkriegsgeschichte pendlern geht im
wahrsten sinne des wortes der sprit aus
die nahrungsmittelpreise sind um sechs
prozent gestiegen die schlangen an den
tafeln werden immer länger und das
einzige was von der bundesregierung dazu
zu hören ist ist cem özdemir der fordert
die preise für lebensmittel zu erhöhen
was braucht es noch um zu erkennen dass
dieses land von einer gesättigten elite
regiert wird die sich vom volk
vollkommen abgekoppelt hat
das ist anders geht zeigt ein blick ins
ausland frankreich hat die strom und
gaspreise gedeckelt und energie checks
für sechs millionen haushalte eingeführt
ungarn hat reagiert österreich hat
reagiert polen hat reagiert dort gibt es
eine kraftstoff steuersenkung auf null
und lebensmittelhilfen für die ärmsten
familien und deutschland bis heute hat
die bundesregierung keine einzige
maßnahme ergriffen ihr war es viel
wichtiger ein quer beauftragten zu
benennen der die interessen der
transsexuellen vertritt und sie meine
damen und herren von den altparteien
streiten sich wie in der vorschule um
die sitzordnung was für eine
peinlichkeit
meine damen und herren peinlich ist auch
der umgang mit einer zentralen
gerechtigkeitsfrage in deutschland die
durchschnittliche rente von frauen mit
drei kindern liegt bei
751 euro ein arbeitsloser afghane der
nie einen cent in unser sozialsystem
einbezahlt hat hat einen anspruch nehmen
wir hamburg von
944 euro sozialhilfe
200 euro mehr als eine frau die eine
lebensleistung erbracht hat die das land
aufgebaut hat die steuern gezahlt hat
und die für zukünftige beitragszahler
gesorgt hat das ist eine schande für die
politik ist es eine schande für
regierungen rief über viele jahre und
jahrzehnte den wählern soziale
gerechtigkeit versprochen haben rund 40
prozent aller hartz 4 empfänger sind
ausländer fast 40 prozent aller
in deutschland lebenden kinder leben in
hartz iv familien 40 prozent der anstieg
von armut in unserem land ist fast
vollständig die folge der zuwanderung
nehmen sie diese realität zur kenntnis
die politik der offenen grenzen ist ein
angriff auf unseren sozialstaat
und sie lernen nichts sie machen immer
weiter noch mehr zuwanderung noch mehr
höhere sozialleistungen wegfall von
sanktionen das alles kann nicht die
lösung sein diese geldgeschenke sind ein
riesengroßer pull faktor um weitere
armut migranten nach deutschland zu
locken
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
steuergeld das sie benötigen um armut
migranten zu finanzieren fällt nicht vom
himmel sondern es wird auch wirtschaftet
von millionen normalverdienern die
tagtäglich hart arbeiten gehen und die
sollten sie mal in den blick nehmen
sie nehmen diese normalverdiener aber
nicht in den blick sie schöpfen sie
einfach weiter statt maßnahmen hier
gegen die inflation anzubieten ziehen
sie ihnen noch mehr geld aus der tasche
um mit ihren ihre welt rettungsfliegern
fantasien zu finanzieren
und im alter lassen sie die leute in
armut zurück was für ein trauerspiel
meine damen und herren so kann es nicht
weitergehen folgen sie dem beispiel
dänemarks das geführt wird von einer
sozialdemokratischen regierung stoppen
sie die armut migration und machen sie
endlich sozialpolitik für das eigene
volk vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
wenn ich möchte sie gerne fragen ob noch
ein mitglied des hauses anwesend ist
dass seine stimme nicht abgeben konnte
bei den wahlen
tatsächlich glaubt es nicht
tatsächlich ist noch ein mitglied des
hauses anwesen dessen namen ich es nicht
nennen werden
hier ist weiß niemand wie es ist
noch mehr
sind noch mehren
ok dann würde ich mal so sagen da ich
diese frage noch einmal gestellt habe
muss ich diese chance auch noch geben
das gibt uns die gelegenheit vor
abschluss der wahlen aber nicht
abschluss der debatte die rede von
johannes vogel zuzuhören der für die fdp
fraktion spricht ja johannes vogel der
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende der
fdp ist jetzt erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der
verehrten damen und herren wenn ich in
den letzten tagen wochen von freunden
bekannten auf die neue koalition
angesprochen werde dann geht es oft erst
mal gar nicht so sehr um inhalte sondern
denn erwähnen die am meisten den stil wo
diese koalition im vergleich zu den
letzten jahren ein unterschied macht von
vertrautheit und vertraulichkeit von
nicht stillstand auf basis des kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenners sondern von guten
kompromissen guten kompromisse die muten
allen seiten etwas zu und das so
fortschritt erreicht werden kann liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und
dass dabei das sage ich meinen blick auf
die union offenbar dieser fortschritts
koalition eine gute balance gelungen ist
das hat zum beispiel die wortmeldungen
von stefan wolff dem präsidenten von
gesamtmetall deutlich gemacht der hat
nämlich explizit mit blick auf das
kapitel arbeit und soziales gesagt na
das ist deutlich besser als der
koalitionsvertrag der großen koalition
wo die union dabei war liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die achten hier die
interessen von unternehmen und betrieben
und unternehmern und mitarbeitern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
und
lieber hermann gröhe hat das thema rente
angesprochen und weist das liegt mir
auch besonders am herzen aber ich finde
schon dass es hat rutscht seitens der
union wo die csu ja mit der forderung
der koalitionsbedingung einer mütter
rente 2 in diesem wahlkampf gezogen ist
den letzten wahlkampf ausgerechnet bei
der rente aus dieser perspektive diese
koalition zu kritisieren wir
stabilisieren die rente liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und bei dem
federn wo wir in dieser
legislaturperiode auch mit blick auf
demografie festigkeit vorankommen können
zum beispiel mehr einwanderungspolitik
die wende mich brauchen in diesem land
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zum
beispiel
bei
der generationengerechtigkeit und dem
nachholfaktor und bei der neuen balance
durch den einstieg in eine teilweise
kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen rente
mit einer aktien rente da stoßen wir die
tür auf zu einer enkel vierten rente auf
den weg haben wir uns gemacht in dieser
koalition liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und das zweite thema was sich kurz
erwähnen will ist dass wir auch den den
stillstand bei der digitalisierung auf
der arbeitswelt in der arbeitswelt
endlich durchbrechen der letzten jahre
ja durch einen ganzen großen wurf bei
der weiterbildung dient in diesem land
bringen braucht und vorrednerin haben
erklärt lieber kolleginnen und co neben
durch modernisierung der regel für home
office zum beispiel und endlich durch
mehr fairness für selbstständige die in
den letzten jahren nämlich zu schlecht
behandelt wurden von den regeln in
diesem land und das ist überfällig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen aber das letzte
das letzte thema was ich erwähnen will
weil es mir besonders am herzen liegt
ist dass wir beim thema
chancengerechtigkeit und
aufstiegschancen endlich vorankommen mit
dem was wir uns in neuen bürgergeld
vorgenommen haben chancengerechtigkeit
und aufstieg das hat nämlich auch eine
sozialpolitische dimension und zum
beispiel dass die zuverdienstregeln bei
der grundsicherung menschen heute eher
in der grundsicherung festhalten anstatt
ihnen eine tritt feste leiter
hinzustellen und
insbesondere die wir mit jungen menschen
mit schülerinnen und schüler in diesem
land umgehen da war eine veränderung
dringend notwendig denn schon bei der
fundamentalen erfahrung des ersten
selbst verdienten geldes macht zb kann
zb auch deren eltern finanziell auf
eigenen beinen stehen vom schüler
minijob 450 euro heute behalten und
annika deren eltern vielleicht auf
hartz4 heute angewiesen sind dass wir
endlich definieren kann davon nur 170
euro behalten das macht etwas aus in den
köpfen schon bei der fundamentalen
erfahrung des ersten selbst verdienten
geldes haben wir bisher das signal in
diesem land das man schlechtere chancen
hat wenn die eltern in schwieriger lage
sind diese ungerechtigkeit schaffen wir
endlich ab und sorgen für mehr fairness
und das ist überfällig liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
drei beispiele für notwendigen
fortschritt auch in der sozialpolitik
ich freue mich auf die arbeit dieser
koalition vielen dank
johannes vogel die erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
fdp-fraktion
dahinten auch ein zeichen schließe ich
die wahl und bitte die schriftführerin
und schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen das ergebnis wird ihnen später
bekannt gegeben
bei dieser wahl geht es um die wahl der
vertreter der so nicht geben rutscht in
der parlamentarischen versammlung des
europarates und diese wahl dauerte jetzt
endlich zweieinhalb stunden jetzt sind
die ohne geschlossen und hier wird
weiter diskutiert im plenum über den
bereich arbeit und soziales susanne
ferschl stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
präsidentin sehr verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen mehr fortschritt wagen so
lautet der titel des koalitionsvertrags
und die frage ist tatsächlich ob dieser
fortschritt bei den beschäftigten im
hinblick auf löhne arbeitsbedingungen
und soziale absicherungen auch ankommt
bei hartz4 dass künftig bürgergeld
heißen soll ist ohne regelsatzerhöhung
das ganze lediglich ein
etikettenschwindel
großen sozialpolitisches projekt dagegen
ist zugegebenermaßen die geplante
erhöhung des mindestlohns auf 12 euro
die linke fordert 12 euro seit 20 17 und
natürlich unterstützen wir das wenn das
projekt jetzt zeitnah umgesetzt wird und
mich persönlich würde es wirklich freuen
damit er möglichst aber gut
muss er endlich flächendeckend
kontrolliert werden und da freut mich
das schon wieder etwas weniger weil das
finanzministerium unter christian
lindner hat ist der für die kontrollen
letztlich dann zuständig ist
macht mich zweifeln die fdp sich bislang
nicht unbedingt als hüterin von
arbeitnehmerrechten aufgefallen
fast 2 bis 200 jahre und gucken sie doch
mal an fast zweieinhalb millionen
menschen werden aktuell um den
mindestlohn betrogen und für echten
fortschritt muss damit endlich schluss
sein
sogar so kann der mindestlohn modi und
dass die auffanglinie seien notwendig
sind gute arbeitsbedingungen und eine
stärkung der tarifbindung und hier
machen sie bisweilen das gegenteil von
dem was notwendig wäre sie weiten
mini-jobs aus ich hatte ja gestern in
der regierungsbefragung schon kritisiert
der bundeskanzler ist es leider nicht da
er hat mir nahegelegt sich soll
statistiken stadt flugblätter lesen das
gebe ich gerne zurück die statistiken
zeigen nämlich deutlich dass die
mini-jobs und kontinuierlich zugenommen
haben und eine studie des ib belegt auch
den verdrängungseffekt der regulären
jobs mini jobs als sprungbrett das in
reguläre beschäftigung es ist ein
neoliberales märchen und ich bin
enttäuscht dass jetzt auch ein spd
kanzler dieses neoliberale märchen
nachplappern
aber weiter im text sie halten und loser
befristung und leiharbeit fest obwohl
leiharbeitnehmer beispielsweise im
schnitt 1400 euro pro monat weniger
entgelt haben als ihre fest angestellten
kolleginnen und kollegen und bei der
tarifbindung planen sie einfach viel zu
wenig obwohl nur noch die hälfte der
beschäftigten unter den schutz eines
tarifvertrages feld für mehr dort
fortschritt müssen sie deutlich
nachbessern machen sie mini-jobs
sozialversicherungspflichtig schaffen
sie leiharbeit und sachgrundlose
befristung ab und erleichtern sie
endlich die
allgemeinverbindlicherklärung von
tarifverträgen
nur dann wird auch gerne geben die nicht
direkt in die altersarmut führen und
zusätzlich muss das rentenniveau rauf 48
prozent sind zu wenig das ist kein
fortschritt ist stagnation
die 53 prozent die wir übrigens auch mal
hatten die wir in finanzierer sie
müssten nur das versicherungssystem
umstellen sie müssten alle
erwerbstätigen also auch selbstständige
auch bundestagsabgeordnete und so weiter
mit einbeziehen das wäre tatsächlich
fortschrittlich
aber nein stattdessen wurde mit dem
einstieg in die aktie rente ein lang
gehegter wunsch der fdp erfüllt und ich
finde es ehrlich sagt reichlich absurd
dass künftig mit renten am kapitalmarkt
spekuliert werden kann
und das gleiche gilt leider auch für das
arbeitszeitgesetz auf wunsch der fdp
soll es per tarifvertrag aufgeweicht
werden können und ich habe lange genug
selber tarifverträge verhandelt um zu
wissen dass jetzt der druck auf die
gewerkschaft zunehmen wird und die
arbeitgeber ein weiteres mittel an die
hand bekommen um schmutzige kompromisse
zu erzwingen der angriff auf den
acht-stunden-tag der ist kein
fortschritt dessen echter rückschritt
und über 100 jahre um genau zu sagen
ich kann ihnen abschließend nur sagen
fortschritt und respekt sind große worte
und es liegt in ihrer verantwortung in
der verantwortung der bundesregierung
dafür zu sorgen dass es nicht zu
worthülsen verkommt wir werden ihnen
jedenfalls dabei immer und immer wieder
auf die finger schauen vielen dank
[Applaus]
dagmar schmid hat das wort für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die generaldebatte ist für die großen
linien und vorhaben und da haben wir uns
unter der überschrift sozialer
fortschritt einiges vorgenommen und das
erste und große ziel das wir uns gesetzt
haben ist es wir wollen den sozialstaat
bürgerfreundlicher machen wir folgen
nicht mehr dem leitgedanken als erstes
gegen die den sozial gegen die den
sozialstaat missbrauchen könnten große
mauern aufzubauen die dann allen im weg
stehen sondern wir wollen den
sozialstaat zuallererst in den dienst
der jähnigen stellen die ihnen brauchen
um ihnen das leben leichter zu machen
denn sein leben in deutschland zu
organisieren ist schon sehr kompliziert
und oftmals anstrengend auch wenn es nur
darum geht die dinge des alltags zu
bewältigen und auch dann wenn nicht
gerade corona ist wenn aber ein
unerwartetes ereignis eintritt eine
krankheit ein pflegefall
arbeitslosigkeit wenn man also es gerade
besonders schwer hat dann schlägt
oftmals die bürokratie des sozialstaats
umso härter zu und das wollen wir
beenden
zb durch die nutzung der digitalisierung
wir wollen dass überall wo das möglich
ist leistungen die den menschen zu
stehen auch automatisch ausgezahlt
werden ohne antrag und ohne dass man
selber von allen behörden unterlagen
beschaffen und sie dann selber wieder
weiterreichen muss mit der grundrente
haben wir das schon angefangen und das
wollen wir fortsetzen zum beispiel mit
der kindergrundsicherung
und wir wollen dass es in zukunft
überall einfach ist sich online zu
informieren beraten zu lassen anträge
und ab fragen zu stellen und das hilft
den allermeisten menschen auch wirklich
gut aber es gibt auch die die das nicht
können die keinen zugang haben und für
die auch der weg aufs amt ein
beschwerlicher weg ist und wir wollen
deshalb den sozialstaat der auch auf
suchend ist der vor ort ist der einfach
zu erreichen ist damit uns niemand
verloren geht und
wir wollen einen sozialstaat mit mehr
individuellen möglichkeiten mit mehr
passgenauigkeit und dazu werden wir
leistungen flexibler machen zum beispiel
durch mehr zeit für die familie wie
durch die bezahlte partner zeit nach der
geburt eines kindes und die erweiterung
der partnermonate und indem wir
haushaltsnahe dienstleistungen
finanziell unterstützen indem wir die
betreuungsangebote für kinder weiter
ausbauen die kinder krankentage erhöhen
und mehr zeitlichen freiraum bei der
pflege von angehörigen schaffen
und durch ein recht auf home office so
dass beschäftigte künftig von zu hause
aus arbeiten können außer sie fahren
einen lkw oder sitzen an der
supermarktkasse aber indem wir auch
regeln festlegen damit niemand im
home-office eine entgrenzung seiner
eigenen arbeitszeit erleben muss
beispielhaft für diesen bürgernahen
sozialstaat ist aber auch das was wir im
kapitel bürgergeld aufgeschrieben haben
und es lohnt sich das hier vielleicht
noch mal nach allen missverständnis
etwas deutlicher auszuführen leistungen
wird wieder anerkannt wer in der
grundsicherung ankommt muss keine angst
haben zu verlieren was er sich schon
erarbeitet hat zwei jahre lang bleiben
vermögen und wohnung unangetastet damit
man sich eben nicht um eine neue wohnung
kümmern muss sondern zeit hat sich um
einen neuen job zu kümmern
und wir gehen respektvoll miteinander um
jede und jeder kann etwas hat stärken
hat lebens erfahrungen und kompetenzen
und die sind nicht immer in einem
zeugnis oder in einer urkunde
festgehalten diese wollen wir aber
herausfinden und auf diese wollen wir
aufbauen und dann in einer teilhabe
vereinbarung unter zustimmung beider
seiten in verständlicher sprache einen
gemeinsamen weg vereinbaren der die
vorstellung und möglichkeiten der
arbeitslosen in den mittelpunkt stellt
dafür schaffen wir den vermittlungs
vorrang ab damit niemand eine arbeit
annehmen muss die nichts taugt und dann
sechs monate später wieder vor der tür
des jobcenters zu stehen wir wollen
echte perspektiven schaffen
und dafür erweitern wir die
möglichkeiten damit es für jeden und
jede passgenau ist vom aufsuchenden
hilfen bis coaching vom nachbarn der
berufsbildung bis zum erlernen von
analogen und digitalen grundfertigkeiten
und wir setzen auf anreize durch boni
bei weiterbildung und prämien für die
die es geschafft haben ja man kann die
frage bürgergeld
allein an der höhe der regelsätze und
den sanktionen festmachen und ja auch
das nehmen wir in angriffe werden die
regelsätze neu berechnen und wir werden
sinnloses sanktionen abschaffen das was
aber wirklich wichtig ist
den arbeitslosen eine ernsthafte
nachhaltige perspektive zu geben indem
wir uns an ihren stärken möglichkeiten
und wünschen orientieren in dem wir uns
zeit nehmen indem wir auf qualifizierung
setzen dafür schaffen wir die
voraussetzung wie es noch nie zuvor
gegeben hat
wir machen das weil das gerecht ist und
war das für die menschen gut ist wir
machen es aber auch weil wir auf
niemanden verzichten können und wollen
und das gilt auch genauso für die
menschen die mit einer beeinträchtigung
leben egal ob sie diese von geburt an
haben oder im lauf des lebens erworben
haben wir wollen dass alle die gleichen
chancen haben und wir wollen und können
auf niemanden verzichten
und um den zugang zur gute arbeit auch
für menschen mit behinderungen zu
erleichtern werden wir unter anderem das
budget für arbeit und ausbildung stärken
und ausbauen und den arbeitsmarkt
insgesamt durchlässiger machen und wir
werden die vierte stufe der
ausgleichsabgabe für die unternehmen
einführen die keine menschen mit
behinderung einstellen denn auch
unternehmen tragen hier eine
gesellschaftliche verantwortung
sozialer fortschritt chancengleichheit
und inklusion bleiben stetige aufgabe
und es gibt noch verdammt viel zu tun
ich freue mich darauf dass wir jetzt
endlich loslegen klick auf
sagt dagmar schmidt stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende auch für den
bereich arbeit und soziales viel
beschäftigt heute den frieden im bereich
des gesundheitsministers hatte sie für
die spd ja auch schon das wort bekommen
axel knoerig jetzt hier für die
cdu/csu es vorsitzende der
arbeitnehmergruppe
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
werten kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
die versuche die mindestlohn-kommission
zu beeinflussen und ein politisch
gewollten mindestlohn festzusetzen sei
es über den nationalen weg oder den
europäischen stellen einen schweren
eingriff in die grundgesetzlich
garantierte tarifautonomie
wortes muss ich erst mal schauen wo die
fdp ist wortlos einen antrag der fdp aus
der vergangenen wahlperiode
der den titel trägt
unabhängigkeit der mindestlohn
kommission garantieren subsidiarität
achten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der fdp ich habe diesen antrag mal
mitgebracht und ich erlaube mir herr
vogel sie nicken schon ich komme nach
einem redebeitrag zu gehen und ich werde
ihnen diese inhalte geben die sie
vergessen
meine damen und herren treffender als
die fdp fraktion unter dem damaligen
vorsitzenden christian lindner hätte ich
es nicht formulieren können es
beschreibt wirklich eindrücklich das
problem des vorgehens von
bundesarbeitsminister heilbar der
anhebung dieses mindestlohns pro krise
und damit auch kein missverständnis
entsteht
es geht um das vorgehen nicht um das
ziel der mindestlohn in deutschland das
sagen wir ganz klar muss höher ausfallen
und muss auch schneller steigen als
bisher
cdu und csu sind
angetreten die regierungsarbeit kritisch
und auch konstruktiv zu begleiten und
deswegen will ich auch unsere position
darlegen wir befürworten die mindestlohn
erhöhung auf 12 euro weshalb erstens die
mindestlohn mit ihr haben tendenziell
stärker unter corona gelitten als sie
gut und durchschnittsverdiener oftmals
haben sie in kritischen bereichen wieder
logistik lebenserhaltende arbeit
geleistet und da sagen wir als union 12
euro sind eine art anerkennung dieser
leistung unter diesen erschwerten
bedingungen
zweitens die mindestlohn bezieher sind
von der gestiegenen inflation nicht
zuletzt war den energiepreisen besonders
hart getroffen meine sozialen
marktwirtschaft ist es der bessere weg
dies über eine höhere entlohnung für
selbst geleistete arbeit zu kompensieren
als durch eine aufstockung der
bundesliga
einige sachen kurt
erwägt inzwischen fragen zu stellen
möchten sie das ganze machen
markus kurth herr knoerig sie geben an
das ziel von 12 euro mindestlohn als
unionsfraktion mit uns zu teilen
sagen aber der weg sei eben nicht der
richtige das hieße also die
mindestlohn-kommission müsste die zwölf
euro fest schreiben
haben sie irgendwelche anhaltspunkte
dafür dass die arbeitgeberseite die bda
gesamtmetall und die anderen
arbeitgeberverbände auch nur die
leiseste andeutung gemacht haben in der
mindestlohn kommission zu diesem schritt
bereit zu sein und wenn sie dafür keine
anhaltspunkte haben wie würden sie denn
dann sonst das von ihnen ja angeblich
auch geteilte ziel erreichen wollen als
es mit einer gesetzlichen änderung
bei der herr kollege kurt sie haben
ihren einstieg gut gewählt sie haben das
gut reflektiert was ich hier zum
ausdruck bringen wollte aber sag ihnen
aber auch eines ganz klar
und das ist das was versucht wird dass
wir uns als union an dem verfahren
festbeißen sollen und sie als regierung
sagen seht ihr die wollen ja im grunde
genommen nicht die zwölf euro und ich
sage ihnen ganz klar das ist mit uns
nicht zu machen wir stehen an der seite
derer die einen mindestlohn bekommen und
ich habe ihnen gerade zwei gute gründe
genannt nicht nur die korona pandemie
die energiepreise die inflation und
deswegen sagen wir das ziel von 12 euro
ist richtig und ich lade sie ein hören
sie weiterhin so aufmerksam ein
redebeitrag zu dann werde ich ihnen auch
gerade noch darlegen wie wir das im
grunde genommen auch gegebenenfalls mit
ihnen auch wenn sie es wünschen
optimieren möchten
ich komme zu meinem dritten punkt
und da gucke ich auch noch mal ihr zur
fdp das sage ich in aller klarheit und
deutlichkeit für uns keines keine
faktische ausschaltung der mindestlohn
gilt das mindestlohn kommission geben
das will ich hier nochmal auf den punkt
bringen meine damen und herren die
gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeberverbände müssen bei der
lohnfindung eingebunden werden und es
ihr geht es nicht und dafür hat ja auch
die spd bei der einführung entsprechend
mit gestimmt und die gewerkschaft müssen
die möglichkeiten haben wenn
erforderlich ihre tarifverträge
nachzuzeichnen und man sieht ja jetzt
auch dass das bis juni juli auch in
teilen auch vorgenommen wird und ich
mache ihnen einen zweiten controller
konstruktiven vorschlag der union
ergänzen sie den auftrag der mindestlohn
kommission um ein kriterium für eine
angemessene alterssicherung bislang
bildet die mindestlohn-kommission die
tariflichen lohnentwicklung nach um die
mindestlöhne das sagen wir schneller
anzuheben zu können sollte die
nachzeichnung beendet werden meine damen
und herren dieser koalition fehlt schon
zu beginn der mut der lage im land ins
gesicht zu sehen das gilt insbesondere
auf die rentenpolitik eine echte reform
der rente ist dringend erforderlich
ihren vielgerühmten doppelten
haltelinien nimmt ihnen angesichts der
demografischen entwicklung
wirklich niemand mehr ab das ist keine
politik des respekts wieder herr
bundeskanzler so gerne sagt das ist das
gegenteil das ist respekt und auch
verantwortungslos
meine damen und herren wir sein leben
lang hart gearbeitet hat er muss auch im
alter ein gutes auskommen haben und
dafür setzen wir uns ein wir brauchen
lösungen
wir brauchen lösungen die über diese
legislaturperiode hinaus auch wirkung
zeigen und daran werden wir entsprechend
mitwirken meine damen und herren sie
werden jetzt sicherlich da gucke ich
auch zur fdp zum vorhaben der
aktienhändler hin aktien rente hinweisen
dass es schön und gut wirklich eine
nette idee aber zehn milliarden euro
werden vorne und hinten nicht
ausreichend um die rente zu sichern
die rentenversicherung hat den 20 21
dargelegt dass sie 340 milliarden euro
an die rednerinnen und redner
ausgeschüttet hat die tendenz ist
steigend deshalb wir brauchen schnell
geld es kommen jetzt die sogenannten
baby boomer zeiten und da wechseln dann
in der mitte des jahrzehnts viele in den
ruhestand und für den langfristigen
aufbau eines kapitalstocks da reicht die
zeit schlichtweg nicht aus wir haben
viel zeit verloren weil die spd eine
aktienbasierte rente wie der teufel das
weihwasser bekämpft hat meine damen und
herren ich frage was ist denn sozialer
als das normalverdiener an den
steigenden aktienkursen
teilhaben zu lassen
und ich betone es müssen alle drei
säulen angegangen werden bei der rente
die privat oder auch die betriebliche
altersvorsorge müssen ebenfalls gestärkt
werden wachen sie endlich auf der kuppe
zum arbeitsministerium auch hier gilt
respekt vor der lebensleistung der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
und das zeigt sich vor allem in dem man
die realität annimmt und dann auch
entsprechend handelt und deswegen sage
ich sagen sie doch mal einen großen wurf
ein drittes thema noch ganz kurz die
pflege minister sparen maniche hat hier
ein gutes fundament vorgelegt da kann
der herr lauterbach trat aufbauen und es
gab jetzt ein urteil des
bundesarbeitsgericht das sich mit der
häuslichen pflege
beschäftigt hat und viele fragen
aufwirft da geht es um 300 400.000
pflege dienstleistende aus
mittelosteuropa
und da sagen wir ganz klar wir wollen
dass unsere älteren mitbürger weiter zu
hause auch mit einem 24 stunden pflege
möglich gemacht wird dass das hier
vollzogen werden darf weiter hinten und
da frage ich mich doch zum blick auf zum
arbeitsministerium warum handeln sie ihr
weg sie haben doch jetzt hier
verantwortung da muss gehandelt herrn
liegenden ducken sich nicht weg wir
helfen gerne mit vorschlägen aber andere
das wissen sie so lebe ihre zeit wäre
dann vorbei gewesen ich danke ihnen frau
präsidentin für die großzügige
überziehung von 40 sekunden es sind
keine das ist gut dass sie das gesagt
haben beide das wird jetzt dazu führen
dass ihr pdf sicherlich hierher kommt
und im nächsten kollegen das sagen wird
wie das weitergeht
schon in beibringt
die präsidentin weist darauf hin wenn
ein redner lange überzogen hat in dem 40
sekunden dann ist es eigentlich üblich
dass der nächste redner aus der fraktion
diese redezeit abgezogen bekommt bei 40
sekunden wäre dass er etwas ungewöhnlich
aber dass jetzt jede linie wurde kann
sich der anschlag habe sich schon mal
darauf gefasst machen dass
die
bündnisgrünen
welt jetzt das wort hier zum bereich
arbeit und soziales
behindertenpolitik ist
menschenrechtspolitik wie notwendig
genau dieses verständnis ist hat sich in
der pandemie politik noch einmal
deutlich gezeigt
risikogruppen sollten doch vorrangig
geschützt werden
trotzdem waren gerade sie die besonders
leid tragen damit in den letzten zwei
jahren viele unterstützungsangebote sind
weggefallen
schutzausrüstung für menschen in
ambulanten settings war mangelware
es kam zu dramatische soziale isolation
von alten menschen und menschen mit
behinderungen und
trotzdem gab es bei ihnen die meisten
todesfälle die dramatik gipfelte aber
genau darin das genau diejenigen die am
gefährlichsten sind und die gleichzeitig
am härtesten für ihren schutz kämpfen
mussten sich sorgen machen müssen im
falle einer sogenannten triage keine
lebensrettenden maßnahmen zu erhalten
die grüne bundestagsfraktion hatte schon
in der letzten wahlperiode
eine anhörung dazu im
gesundheitsausschuss initiiert
regelungen hat die alte bundesregierung
nicht getroffen deshalb war es so
wichtig dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt im
dezember geurteilt hat
wir müssen unverzüglich eine gesetzliche
regelung finden die ausschließt dass
menschen mit behinderung im fall einer
trias benachteiligt werden ich bin froh
dass justizminister buschmann daran
arbeitet
für einen ausdruck in der garantie der
vollen grund und menschenrechte für
menschen mit behinderung haben wir uns
drei zentrale bereiche vorgenommen
barrierefreiheit teilhabe am
arbeitsleben und eine inklusive
gesundheitsversorgung
unser aller leben findet größtenteils in
der bereits fertig gebauten umwelt statt
und hier wirken barrieren auch am
hartnäckigsten
deshalb verpflichten wir die
privatwirtschaft zum abbau von barrieren
mit entsprechenden förderprogrammen
verhindern wir eine überlastung von
kleinstunternehmen nach verkehrspläne
können immer noch ausnahmen bei der
pflicht zur herstellung von
barrierefreiheit definieren das beenden
wir zum jahr 20 26
menschen sollen so lange und so
sieht wirklich am arbeitsleben teilhaben
können auch die ausgleichsabgabe die
vierte stufe hat schon frau kollegin
schmidt hingewiesen
gleichzeitig gibt es eine scharfe
diskussion
während die einen werkstätten für
menschen mit behinderung für einen teil
des inklusiven arbeitsmarktes halten
sehen die anderen in ihnen genau ein
teil des problems und fordern deren
komplette abschaffung
der richtige ort für die debatte darüber
die alle menschen mitnimmt ist eine
enquetekommission zur umsetzung der
un-behindertenrechtskonvention
mit den schwerpunkten teilhabe am
arbeitsleben bildung und
gesundheitsversorgung
wir werden sie hier auf alle
demokratischen parteien zugehen dann
gleichberechtigten zugang zur
gesundheitsversorgung
gibt es noch einiges zu tun wie
lebensnotwendig assistenz im krankenhaus
ist hat die pandemie doch drastisch
unterstrichen wir müssen die lücken
schließen in der aus und fortbildung des
medizinischen personals müssen viel
stärkeren fokus auf die teilhabe von
menschen mit behinderungen legen und
gerade familien mit schwerst mehrfach
behinderten kindern waren so extrem
belastet sie dann endlich in den fokus
wir werden bis zum ende des jahres einen
aktionsplan für ein die wert und wo sie
bis um barrierefreies gesundheitswesen
vorlegen ich freue mich darauf dass wir
all diese dinge jetzt gemeinsam angehen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
seine ersten regel hat jetzt das wort
der kollege hans nau für die fdp für die
afg faktum
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich bin aus der uckermark für meine
parteien dieses haus eingezogen um
insbesondere für die anliegen meiner
ostdeutschen landsleute einzutreten für
anliegen die von den verschiedenen
regierungskoalitionen seit der wende
angeblich bereits vertreten worden sind
natürlich ganz vorn dabei die
sozialdemokraten dieselben parolen
fordern gerechte rente und fairer
bezahlung begleiten uns ja nun schon
seit jahrzehnten und auf diesem best off
ticket stehen sie nun den bundeskanzler
doch wie steht es tatsächlich um die
soziale lage in unserem land sie haben
von einem ostdeutschen kollegen die
springer dazu bereits einiges gehört nun
in 2020 im auftaktjahr der korona panik
waren über 16 prozent des gesamten
volkes von armut betroffen das sind 13,4
millionen bürger vor allem bedenklich
dabei
alleinerziehende und kinderreiche paare
haben das höchste armutsrisiko alle
haushaltstypen so viel zu ihrer
familienpolitik meine damen und herren
und in meiner märkischen heimat sind
drei jahrzehnte nach der
wiedervereinigung über einen drittel
aller vollzeitbeschäftigten im
niedriglohnsektor tätig was tun sie von
der ampel dagegen sie bauen mini-jobs
aus und schaffen mehr minirenten fast
ein viertel aller deutschen über 80
jahre gilt bereits heute als arm jeder
dritte rentner muss mit einer rente von
unter 1000 euro auskommen obwohl sie 40
jahre oder länger eingezahlt haben und
in ostdeutschland müssen 40 prozent der
rentner mit genau solchen mini renten
auskommen tendenz steigend
in ihrem koalitionsvertrag dazu etwas
mehr als eine seite
minimalkonsens der ampel farbigen
widersprüche keine lösung keine konzepte
und deswegen keine fähren renten
hörte kollegen der regierungsparteien
und insbesondere der spd sie haben die
sozialen probleme in unserem land nicht
annähernd gelöst und die
sozialdemokratisch geführte
linksliberale ampelkoalition wird sie
lediglich und anstreichen mit ihrer
politik der spaltung von um in der emv
debatte ihrer kopflosen energiewende und
der gezielten fragmentierung unserer
gesellschaft durch migration und
sozialliberaler kultur experimente
werben sie die künstlich erzeugten
konflikte und den wohlstandsverlust
unseres landes nur noch mehr
beschleunigen aber vielleicht wird ja
ihr neuer staatsminister für
ostdeutschland und gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse im gegensatz zum
vorherigen ost beauftragten zur
abwechslung mal nicht volk und land
beschimpfen das meine damen und herren
wäre zumindest ein kleiner
hoffnungsschimmer
vielen dank
hannes klopp war das für die afg hier
mit seiner ersten rede im parlament der
nächste redner hier in der debatte über
den bereich arbeit und soziales kommt
von der fdp
passte pascal kober er sprecher für
arbeitsmarkt- und sozialpolitik seiner
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir im
koalitionsvertrag uns dazu bekennen dass
wir hinter uns lassen wollen und das
bürgergeld einführen wollen da steht da
ganz ganz oben drüber das bekenntnis und
das ziel das wir zur gesellschaftlichen
teilhabe befähigen wollen und dass wir
die potenziale der menschen in den
mittelpunkt stellen wollen und das ist
unser ziel denn das ist entscheidend
dass sich entscheidende frage lieber
hermann gröhe wie wir aus einem
problemen endlich mal rauskommen
kanzlerschaft angela merkel angesprochen
in den letzten 16 jahren ist es eben
nicht gelungen die zahl der
langzeitarbeitslosen mal dauerhaft unter
700.000 zu drücken und das 700.000 zu
bringen und das liegt eben auch daran
wie wir mit den menschen umgehen auch in
den jobcentern und deshalb sagen wir wir
müssen die potenziale der menschen in
den mittelpunkt stellen und die
befähigung der menschen in den
mittelpunkt
denn wir wollen den wiedereinstieg und
den einstieg in arbeit ermöglichen mehr
menschen als bisher deshalb braucht es
eine tritt feste leiter in das
arbeitsleben und deshalb ist ganz
entscheidend sagt schmidt hat es auch
erwähnt was ganz zu beginn steht eines
eingliederungs prozesses und da sagen
wir da wollen wir zunächst einmal ganz
sorgfältig und einfühlsamen sage ich
auch mal ein solches wort die
fähigkeiten der menschen die kompetenzen
der menschen
feststellen mit ihnen gemeinsam ihnen
sagen du kannst was du bist mehr und wir
schaffen was gemeinsam und das ist das
neue an diesem bürgergeld das vertrauen
in die kompetenzen der menschen in die
möglichkeiten der menschen und daran
wollen wir arbeiten
und nach dieser kompetenz stellung zu
der auch ganz explizit die feststellung
von soft skills haben wir es genannt
gehört also dinge die man vielleicht
bisher noch gar nicht zertifizieren
konnte in unserem system der abschlüsse
wie wir sie bisher kennen
da baut etwas drauf auf und zwar die
forderung von grundkompetenzen und
weitere förderung und ausbau von
ausbildungen bis hin zu voll
qualifizierten ausbildungen das ist das
was wir machen müssen weil es muss um
die nachhaltigkeit die integration gehen
und das ist das woran wir in den
nächsten vier jahren arbeiten werden
und dazu gehört natürlich auch dass wir
den vermittlungs vorrang abschaffen dazu
gehört auch dass wir das coaching zum
regelinstrument gemacht haben oder
machen werden weil es darum gehen wer
hat die menschen zu unterstützen
begleiten bei einer ausbildung bei einem
einstieg in den beruf aber auch in
allgemeine lebensfragen das ist auch
eine erkenntnis der letzten jahre das
coaching funktioniert und deshalb werden
wir es zum regelinstrument machen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und weil ja leider in unserem land gilt
dass die chancen im erwerbsleben der
bildungserfolg zu stark vom elternhaus
abhängen und da sage ich ganz
ausdrücklich der hdk schäferling die
richtige idee den 16h auf den weg zu
bringen wir haben wir die möglichkeiten
des sechzehners ausweiten um mehr
menschen auch in früheren lebensjahren
schon zu erreichen und auch das ist
etwas was wir uns auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben und schlussendlich
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zum
menschenbild gehört auch dass
eigeninitiative natürlich anerkannt
werden muss wir wollen eine ermutigende
sozialstaat und deshalb gehört es eben
auch dazu dass wir die
zuverdienstgrenzen verbessern und das
sind die wegmarken die wir ebenso
erreichte langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
verfolgen neben vielen anderen dingen in
der sozialpolitik ich wünsche dem
minister hubertus heil dass er bald
wieder bei uns sein kann wir freuen uns
auf die zusammenarbeit mit ihm mit den
kolleginnen in der fraktion für die
menschen in unserem land fielen dann
so nach pascal kober kommt jetzt der von
mir vorhin schon erwähnte stephan
stracke speicher für arbeit und soziales
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
14 minuten redezeit zu ich bin gespannt
wie streng die sitzung
sehr verehrten damen und herren die
heutige debatte zeigt er in der
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik steuert
diese links gelbe koalition mit vollgas
nach links von gelb ist weit und breit
nichts mehr zu sehen das gilt für die
wesentlichen teile von politik was die
mindestlohn angeht wir sehen dass hier
ein politischer mindestlohn gesetzt wird
und feste regeln
daran sieht nicht mehr orientiert wird
insbesondere auch was die beschlüsse der
mindestlohn kommission angeht wenn man
sich die mindestlohn ansieht dann wird
er noch ein weiteres gemacht nämlich
nicht nur dass man den mindestlohn
politisch festsetzen und damit dem
überbietungswettbewerb tür und tor
öffnet für die zukunft sondern auch dass
man auf europäischer ebene sagt wir
orientieren uns hier an dem
durchschnittseinkommen und damit am
median lohn und dafür reicht auch noch
die fdp die hand wohl wissend dass dies
ein kompetenz- widriger eingriff der eu
in diese gestaltung der mitgliedstaaten
in diesem bereich ist was den
arbeitszeit angehen
auch hier die kolonie käse hatte gezeigt
dass wir viel deutlicher und viel besser
den arbeitsort flexibilisieren können
aber wenn der arbeitsort flexibel wird
dann muss dies auch für die arbeitszeit
gelten viele menschen in unserem land
sehnen sich danach sich die arbeitszeit
frei einteilen zu können sie wollen
nicht mehr dieses in acht stunden
konzept haben sondern sich ihre arbeit
in der woche frei ein teilen können das
wäre wichtig würde der vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf das wäre wichtig für
die vereinbarkeit von pflege und beruf
und was tut links gelb
experimentierklausel und der engsten
voraussetzungen das sind doch keine
überzeugenden lösungen wir brauchen ein
modernes arbeitsrecht 1 dass
rechtssicherheit schafft wir wollen dass
arbeitszeiten sich nach den bedürfnissen
der menschen richten und sich nicht die
menschen nach den arbeitszeiten richten
müssen in diesem jahr
und was die rente betrifft die
alterssicherung ist dank der letzten 16
jahre stabil in deutschland aufgestellt
aber natürlich schleicht sich der
demografische wandel immer spürbarer ein
und ab dem jahr 2025 wird der
handlungsdruck immer stärker und die fdp
sie hat uns kritisiert dass wir die
doppelte haltelinien eingeführt haben
sie haben gesagt es sei fatal dass eine
manipulation der rentenreform und der
rentenformel zu lasten der jüngeren wir
haben das zeitlich befristet gemacht bis
2025 aus wohlüberlegten gründen jetzt
reicht die fdp die hand dafür dass der
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor nämlich die gute
balance zwischen den jüngeren und den
eltern was die lasten angeht das
demografischen wandels dass die
nachhaltig und dauerhaft beseitigt
werden das ist das gegenteil von
generationengerechtigkeit das ist das
gegenteil von dem was sie im wahlkampf
immer wieder gesagt haben und was tut
die fdp sie rühmt sich dafür jetzt einen
kapitalstock aufzubauen von zehn
milliarden euro zum vergleich die
eigenes modell sieht mindestens 100
milliarden euro vor übrigen als
zusätzlicher staatsverschuldung aber 100
milliarden euro um überhaupt eine
sinnvolle rendite erwirtschaften zu
können zum vergleich gegeben an allein
an bundeszuschüssen 100 milliarden euro
jährlich aus sie bauen einen
kapitalstock von zehn milliarden das ist
kein großer wurf sie wurden klein
geschreddert innerhalb dieser ampel
koalition und was wichtig wäre wäre
jetzt ein mutiger 1 echter schritt nach
vorne und das wäre beispielsweise eine
generation in rente die wir einführen
müssten bei der der staat für jedes kind
jeden monat bis zum 18 lebensjahr an die
rente 100 euro einzahlt und das geld
dann auch renditeorientiert anruft das
was links gelb tut ist zu wenig es ist
zu falsch und es reicht nicht um die
rente zu sichern
die richter waren starke durfte dann
doch seine ganze redezeit benutzen
martin rosemann wird der nächste
sprecher ich teile das ordentliche
kleinen speicher für arbeit und soziales
wer ist der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden
bereich der ist für die
bundestagssitzung
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir haben in
den letzten monaten
mit dem kurzarbeitergeld
erfolgreich in der korona pandemie
arbeit gesichert und das zeigt nicht nur
dass die kurzarbeit die brücke über
diese krise ist sondern es zeigt vor
allem wie wichtig ein handlungsfähiger
sozialstaat ist der zielgenau hilft
deswegen
und deswegen ist es die agenda dieser
ampelkoalition unseren sozialstaat so
weiterzuentwickeln dass er in konkreten
lebenslagen unterstützt
unbürokratisch zugewandt auf augenhöhe
oder zusammengefasst bürgerfreundlich
und damit dass dieser sozialstaat einen
beitrag dazu leistet dass wir als
gesellschaft die grossen
herausforderungen der globalisierung der
digitalisierung und des technologischen
und demografischen wandels bewältigen
und das vor allem diejenigen die in
diesem wandel mit veränderungen zu tun
haben die diesen wandel besonders bitter
ist dass die die unterstützung erfahren
die sie brauchen um in diesem wandel
klar zu kommen ein sozialstaat er für
die leute das leben leichter macht
und
wir wollen ein sozialstaat er für
zusammenhalt sorgt und deshalb meine
damen und herren erhöhen wir den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro ja wir machen
das wir erzählen nicht nur herr knoerig
dass es unser ziel sondern wir sagen
auch wie das geht und wir machen das
auch als ampelkoalition das ist
das ist nämlich eine gehaltserhöhung für
fast zehn millionen beschäftigte und das
ist eine frage des respekts des respekts
gegenüber menschen die jeden morgen
aufstehen sich anstrengen und sich an
die regeln halten
aber klar klar ist auch gute löhne und
gute arbeitsbedingungen für alle das
muss natürlich mehr sein als ein
mindestlohn von 12 euro und deswegen
wird diese regierung alles dafür tun die
tarifbindung wieder zu stärken und wir
wollen dafür sorgen und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass es gute arbeitsbedingungen
auch in zeiten der digitalisierung gibt
das auch beschäftigte von
digitalisierung profitieren wir wollen
die digitalisierung nutzen um arbeit
besser zu machen dafür zu sorgen dass es
arbeit gibt die zum leben passt und
deswegen werden wir unter anderem einen
rechtsrahmen für mobile arbeit schaffen
mit mehr rechten für die beschäftigten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ob
bei veränderungen durch die
digitalisierung oder durch den
technologischen wandel
es gilt dass veränderung gestaltet
werden muss und es geht nur auf
augenhöhe zwischen den arbeitgebern und
ihren beschäftigten und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir die mitbestimmung an
die anforderungen dieser zeit anpassen
damit diese gestaltung auf augenhöhe
auch möglich ist
arbeit arbeit meine damen und herren ist
wichtig für uns alle für unsere eigenes
leben aber auch zentral für unseren
gesellschaftlichen wohlstand und
deswegen ist unser anspruch als ampel
dass wir allen einen platz geben einen
platz auf dem sie sich produktiv mit
ihren möglichkeiten einbringen können
und das gilt auch für menschen mit
handicaps und deswegen werden wir den
arbeitsmarkt durchlässiger inklusiver
machen und deshalb werden wir den
sozialen arbeitsmarkt in fristen und
weiterentwickeln unser anspruch
unser anspruch ist es menschen zu veh
gerade bei veränderungen unser anspruch
ist es dafür zu sorgen dass der
sozialstaat als partner in der
transformation für sicherheit und
chancen sorgt und deshalb bauen wir die
unterstützung bei aus- und weiterbildung
die unterstützung bei beruflicher
neuorientierung
bauen wir diese aus für arbeitsuchende
genauso wie für beschäftigte damit diese
die arbeit von morgen machen können
und
wir nehmen auch die gesundheit von
beschäftigten in den blick deshalb
stärken wir events ionen und
rehabilitation meine damen und herren
eine neue weiterbildungs kultur und
gesunde arbeit das ist für jeden und
jeder einzelne beschäftigte wichtig aber
es ist ebenso wie mehr zuwanderung und
die vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
auch wichtig für die fachkräftesicherung
und damit auch für die sicherung der
altersvorsorge denn ein guter
sozialstaat sorgt für sicherheit gerade
auch im alter und deswegen werden wir
als ampel die gesetzliche rente stärken
wir schaffen langfristige
verlässlichkeit beim sicherungsniveau
wir werden altersvorsorge auch für
selbstständige organisieren und wir
werden auch für die
erwerbsminderungsrente rinnen und
rentner im bestand für verbesserungen
sorgen
meine damen und herren
kommen sie bis zum schluss es geht um
bürgerinnen und bürger die ansprüche und
rechte haben gegenüber dem sozialstaat
sie sind keine bittstellerin und
bittsteller und es ist auch eine frage
des respekts hat doch der große mann
werden wir die grundsicherung zum
bürgergeld
weiterentwickeln sozialer fortschritt
meine damen und herren dafür sorgt
dafür arbeiten
martin rosemann war das natürlich nicht
der vertreter fraktionsvorsitzender
sondern sprecher für arbeit und soziales
da habe ich alle verwirrt das tut mir
leid es gab ja viele wahlen viele neue
positionen da kann das vollständig die
lebensverhältnisse in diesem haus die
jetzt als letzte rednerin hier zu
arbeiten
von dem bündnis gelungen sie haben das
nur ist tatsächlich der vertrieb die
fraktion zu sitzen in dem fall aber wird
noch ist keine pause frau präsidentin
mein name ist wieder auf genau
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lieber an den fernsehgeräten
veränderungen braucht halt veränderungen
braucht sicherheit
das ist uns grünen glaube ich noch viel
präsenter als vielen anderen weil wir
einfach wissen was für eine gewaltige
aufgabe nicht für veränderungen gehen
den nächsten zehn jahren nächsten 30
jahren vor uns haben eine klimaneutrale
wirtschaft und gesellschaft geht nicht
ohne soziale sicherheit und ohne
sozialen ausgleich und genauso war es
aber das eben die soziale sicherheit und
der soziale ausgleich nicht mehr geht
wenn wir diese veränderung nicht machen
wenn wir nicht hinkommen zu
klimaneutralen wirtschaft und
gesellschaft das ist unser anspruch an
diesem koalitionsvertrag und wir sagen
den grünen haben geliefert
[Applaus]
die ganze breite gute bereits
dargestellt verband kollegen frank
bsirske hilfe meiner kollegin stephanie
heckner ich möchte noch mal kurz daran
erinnern 12 euro mindestlohn ja das ist
eine gewaltige verbesserung für
millionen von menschen in diesem land
das ich eben arbeit tatsächlich wieder
lohnt und auch die reform des
bürgergeldes frau seine fesche klar wir
hatten uns da wir von der summe her mehr
gewünscht aber wir machen eine
grundlegende reform des hartz-iv-systems
und geschaffen das bürgergeld die
vermögensverteilung das eben die leute
nicht mehr angst haben müssen um ihre
wohnungen das eben zukünftig die
vereinbarungen auf augenhöhe passiert
das eben der vermittlungs vorrang nicht
mehr existiert all diese punkte sind
eine grundlegende veränderung und
ermöglichen dass endlich wieder auch
menschen die in dem bezugssystem sind
sich im jobcenter auch angemessen und
auf augenhöhe begegnet fühlen und das
ist der neue geist dieser koalition das
werde nur umwelt meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
ganz entscheidend ist aber eben auch
klasse was wir zum thema rente in dieser
koalition vereinbart haben wir müssen
eben die leistungsfähigkeit der
gesetzlichen rente sichern die
gesetzliche rente in deutschland ist
einfach eine errungenschaft um die uns
ganz viele länder außerhalb von
deutschland beneiden kein privates
produkt ist so leistungsfähig wie die
gesetzliche rente und deswegen war es
ihm so wichtig dass wir das
mindestniveau verankert haben 48 prozent
darauf können sich jetzt die leute
verlassen in diesem land
und wir bauen es aus bürgerversicherung
auch die selbständigen werden zum
entsprechenden angemessenen konditionen
zukünftige berücksichtigt werden
bekommen sie wirklich schluss up haus zu
einer sicheren rente eindruck dass offen
geblieben die private altersvorsorge da
sind wir nicht weit genug in den
verhandlungen das wird ganz zentral auf
der tagesordnung stehen weil wir ein
drei säulen system haben und wir
brauchen auch eine verbesserung ein
neues grundlegende reform des systems
zur privaten altersvorsorge und
verbesserung stärkung der betrieblichen
altersvorsorge rathaus bietet kommen sie
zum schluss in
letzter sekunde das müsst ihr mehrfach
von grieg greifen weil die rede weitere
wortmeldungen das war zu diesem
themenbereich
nicht vor